hello there
reject nation I'm Greg Alba and I'm John
Humphrey we're gonna watch the trailer
for John wick Parabellum pepper album
Terrebonne I don't like big words we're
probably the last ones to get our
trailer reaction up I'm gonna kill them
I'm gonna kill them all Oh Oh before we
hop into this trailer guys I wanted to
say thank you to each and every one of
your sons up b-words who I've been
downloading and following us on the
Stardust app over there we post 30
second reaction reviews for any film TV
show and or trailer some of them are
micro sketches it's a total blasty blast
and a place you want to be it's free to
download free to you soo do today
it's a piece of it
I love this literal ticking time clock
okay
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Laughter]
looks like it's hard
the dogs are getting some dogs fight
back this time around the only place
left to go was ass-kicking dogs I
remember one of our like we both loved
the first John wig and I really enjoy
the second John wick I don't like it as
much as the first but this seems to have
some aesthetic that harkens back a
little bit more to the first one
specifically in terms of its
cinematography oh yeah yeah all the neon
lighting and the expressive imagery and
stuff like that yeah definitely that was
something I was missing in the second
one a bit more the second one felt a bit
more grungy and sort of handheld and
this one definitely feels like it's
bringing back some of the sleekness yeah
yeah and I like how the the consistency
of this keeps going where each one picks
up not like the minute after but but
soon right around the time yeah this
looks like it could be like two hours
later or something like that why not
what's the time limit before he is an
hour oh yeah to get away right yeah yeah
this would be like within the hour cuz
that moment where he's with the that guy
who's like stitching him up for whatever
it's like five seconds
yeah that's you know till DX comunicados
goes live and everybody can hunt down
and he's just trying to find a way he's
gonna have to shoot his way out of here
and I love that taking time clock that
level of real suspense you know and that
that was something that I did feel took
a while to kick in that the level of
suspense in the second one and this
seems like it's just gonna start off
with that like you are really gonna get
thrusted into this environment and they
always amp up the set pieces you know I
love that moment with you know I said
UKUSA where the guys are like on
motorcycles or yeah and it seems like
they're amping up some things we might
have seen in some other movies you know
that thing where there's like mirrors
bad guy and mirrors and they're cheating
the way through
I find that kimete an occasional
annoying trope in a lot of action flicks
however something tells me they're going
to
something pretty unique with this I mean
yeah John wick has that reputation of
like well I'll kind of take a look at
whatever they're gonna bring to
something I've seen before because it
usually seems like the action is where
these movies sing the loudest and they
always have creative takes on set pieces
yeah bone-crunching combat you know well
what the action I was thinking of you
know Jason Bourne because of the book
yeah write this right now via a that's
what I mean it's like okay Jason Bourne
hits a guy with a book but in this one
no he's gonna put it right in the mouth
and slam it in there it's gonna be
brutal you know and I love those
editions and it seems like he is going
up the main big he's the guy in the
mirror looks like an Asian guy you know
so maybe maybe yeah there is something
to do with like Yakuza because I I
remember the writer of this talked about
wanting to do some kind of Nomad story
where John wicks in Japan doesn't look
like that it was like still in New York
City but at least it seems to be trying
some sort of inspiration from that
happens there I think so it might be
that I really can't tell I mean that
that that sequence I was teased unlike
stuff like Instagram and Twitter with
yeah I know Arnold did it first or True
Lies but come on it's gonna be John wick
style and we've commentated on this
before it seems like a lot of movies do
this Uncharted thing Indiana Jones thing
John wicks out in the desert now it's
Aquaman did it's a thing that goes on in
that a lot of A&M IV international
Ritter shows they're going to some spot
like that
yeah here yeah either going to some type
of dune yeah and it's like the most
random shot in the trailer to so I'm
very curious as to how it fits anywhere
well it seems like he's going to meet up
with Halle Berry's
Sofia in that moment at least that's how
it communicated to me here that she's
hiding out somewhere there maybe maybe
the Continental is underneath the sand
yeah they've got over there high-risk
members
[Laughter]
archaeological continental the roots the
origins of all all this beginning so
yeah and Halle Berry looks cool too man
yeah yeah good addition to the cast I
mean that's you know another one of the
charms of John wick is like who they
gonna add this time yeah i'm carrie anne
moss Halle Berry yeah no I know part 4
will be carrie anne moss and he'll like
ride a scooter skateboard or something
or just mix it up again well i would
love that
i might love that i mean the director
chad Celski was talking about how he
wishes he could just do this forever
like he does long he really loves being
invested in this world and i'm very
curious because part to open up the
world in a way I didn't anticipate like
it got so much deeper in its roots what
do they call the group the ones who run
the Continental like the heads of the
table the high table yeah yeah the high
table it was he talking with someone
from the high table there when he was
saying I want passage I was wondering
about that too I mean I I certainly
wouldn't put it past them then you know
maybe he finds a way to get somebody
from the high table into a compromising
position and gets leverage or whatever
but it could also be somebody completely
removed from you yes you know I guess
what gets me excited about this in the
way that it's being executed at least
from just this trailer the first one
felt like a very personal action movie
and that's what made it so gripping I
think that's why we were so invested in
John wick and the second one was more
like rock'n'roll kill yeah and I kind of
get a vibe I should look at what
Parabellum means but and I kind of get a
vibe that this is a little bit of both
of something that has its real personal
emotional stakes but will also be that
rock and roll action yeah simultaneously
so this could be the best of both worlds
and in my opinion yeah I'm hoping and
now we just got to see how he delivers
that dialogue yeah before we wrap this
video up I want to give a patron today
shout out to man name
diego Chaidez Diego it's been a long
time since you and I have talked with
one another and I miss you man
what have you been up to how was your
Christmas bin
how was your New Year's do you have a
new year's resolution to slay more
[ __ ] in the field because without a
doubt you are possibly one of the top
two best looking people I've ever seen
at our patreon page men and women
combined I Love You Man
send me a message and we'll talk
you guys can subscribe to the recheck
nation click that notification bell to
get notified every time one of our
videos is up I was also in the movie
replicas this month and it was great you
could love you check us out on patreon
we do TV show reaction watch the longest
weekly qts and music video cuz you
couldn't be trying to
[Music]